alan
i'm curious i mean what was it that made
you wait so long to direct another movie
was it something that just happened
because of how busy you've been
with doing tv or was it because it's
just
hard to get these types of movies made
these days uh
yes yes um
i was busy with true blood uh after true
blood i did uh
um i spent a couple of years developing
and shooting a pilot for an hbo series
that ended up not going i did one season
of a series
for hbo that ended up not going after uh
the first season and uh so that so i was
pretty busy um but also it's difficult
to get a little movie like this made
um i think you know the people who are
in charge of the purse strings
uh read the script and they're like will
this make me money
and i think probably the answer to a lot
of people who read this script was no i
we don't we
we love the writing we love the story
but we don't think this is going to make
us money so thank you
um and and then uh
miramax was the first uh was the first
uh
finance year that we met with who said
yeah we'll do it
so that's that's what took so long paul
was was the script your first impression
of this project or did you talk to
alan first did you just read the story
cold because i would imagine a story
like this would make a pretty emotional
impact when you read it
alan's a pretty classy chap who doesn't
need
to um to preface the read with the
with the with the phone call i'm always
slightly suspicious on it
i'm always slightly like what's wrong
with the script just show me the script
you know you know what i mean it's like
and a really really simple uh note
i also um i also never read letters from
directors because
i i always like i never read a mood book
when they send a lot of mood book as
well
yeah i love all of these movies uh you
know the last picture show is a great
movie yeah
um but it doesn't mean your movie is
going to be like that
so um alan's note was really
really short which was i'd love you to
be in my movie
and i was incredibly flattered being a
big
alan ball fan so but then i wondered
because i'm very much of glasses half
empty sort of chat
i wondered whether i was going to get
the one [ __ ] alan ball spirit
uh and i was really really thrilled to
find out i hadn't
and um some poor other [ __ ] got that
one
uh but i got i got the good one and uh
and uh then we got on the phone and just
we we had an amazing
uh conversation and
and then we pootled off to north
carolina to make the movie and
laughed our way
through uh you know a very emotional
shoot but we laughed we laughed our
asses on
we laughed a lot alan what was it that
made you
see paul in this role and paul what was
it that made you see yourself
in the wrong room before i sent the
script i i
watched a lot of i i well obviously i
had seen a lot of paul's
paul's movies over the years but i i was
watching
um a movie called journey's end
about soldiers in world war one in this
bunker and
basically they all knew they were gonna
die and um
and paul's character uh had
such dignity and decency and grace
and um i remember thinking that's
i can see him playing uncle frank uh
send him the script and then on when the
the phone conversation that he just
referenced um
it was very clear very clear to me that
he got the script he understood it it
spoke to him uh
on a personal level that it would become
a personal thing for him
uh to play the role and that he was a
really great guy and that he was funny
and
and kind and smart and
uh and uh that's you know and that's
when we said let's get our
business people on the phone with each
other and make this work
i thought anybody who likes a version of
me where i have fake
dignity and decency
probably going to be easy to full uh for
five weeks
uh so i said yeah um
no i i why did i do it i uh
it's a really good question you know my
first question
was should i do it you know as a
as a as a straight man and i
and can i do this and um
and i you know just genuinely asking
that question because i
think it gets harder and harder as you
get older as an actor
to you know
to kneel in front of a grave in front of
a camera
in front of a crew and do some play
acting and it's really it gets
it's it's like going to a therapist at
50. it's like gets a bit more
embarrassing the older you are
and i i are talking about yourself
and i um i i need more and more
compelling reasons to
to sit there with my debt brothers
t-shirts
you know and
and go to dark places and actually i got
asked a question by journalists today
that was the
most empathetic question that i'd ever
been asked by journalist ever and then
saying how do you
raise that sort of energy and what about
your mental health and it is true there
are
you you alan sent me home
after we shot the scene at the grave
because he realized that i was
unshootable on
and frankly it was a friday
and i spent the weekend drinking too
much and unable to sleep because i
you'd gone to this place that you just
you that
i don't know there's something there's
one thing it's one thing to be doing at
20 years old somehow and at 50 when
you've got
kids and [ __ ] dogs and stuff
in your life it's you you need a really
good reason to
to do it and i i think that we've i
think
i think we found one so uh there i was
with my brother's t-shirt a
grave again
paul as a director yourself i mean alan
is a master when it comes to these
intimate family ensemble stories what do
you learn
from being directed by somebody like him
and watching him work is there anything
in the way that he works or approaches
material
that you'll carry with you the next time
you direct
oh yeah i mean first of all i'm
resistant to calling myself the director
i think you gotta get
two under your belt when you know one is
like a mistake or something
so do you really mean it and i haven't
done two yet so i
maybe i'll start calling myself a
director if i direct the second one but
yes is the answer and i think
actually we have a sort of similar style
in that i
really love actors because um
they can make you look like you know
what you're doing as a director
that's why i kind of discovered and
um and also i think
alan you know i i happen to have written
the thing that i directed as well and
alan was talking the other day and i
felt entirely
aligned with him on it i
i'm not very precious about what i what
i wrote once i've
written it and and and
as long as the story survives the
actor's idea i don't know well let's go
with that idea it seems to make you feel
really comfortable doing it and that
this
you do a quick calculation in your head
and you think well the story
survives and and oftentimes
you the actor will push back on
a good actor will push back on things
okay
so a good actor is not protecting you as
the director he's not trying to or
you as the producer he's not trying to
or she's not trying to help you make
your day
they're trying to protect the object in
the same way you are
and and they'll push back on on things
it's nice when they push back and the
the lights aren't burning and that
i was gonna say films not in the camera
but we don't do that any longer but you
you know what i mean um
but um alan likes
actors and i like actors and so i think
what i took was being really
what i will take is being really
empathetic and really
i'm really listening because often
somebody's had a better idea yeah
alan do you feel that you're all of your
extensive tv experience
helps when you're directing films i mean
is there any ways that
the experience you've had doing
television changes or affects how you
approach film
well all the films i have done have been
like low budget
films with the not really enough time
to actually do the movie so
all the experience i have uh in tv of
shooting you know five six seven pages a
day
uh is really helpful uh because i'm used
to that schedule i'm used to
um moving at that pace uh
i've never had an experience where i've
directed anything uh for a feature
where i had like a a really
nice amount of time and all the
resources necessary to do it
so i've actually in my experience in tv
uh the last
few shows i've done i've actually had
have had
more in terms of resources uh
than i have with with films um
so i hope i answered your question i
sort of rambled
yeah no you really didn't i think i
think that's true i think
the the problem with making independent
movies now is that we spend so much time
trying to make them look like we had
more time
rather than just have full time exactly
exactly well paul we now today
know that one division is coming out in
january oh yeah did that happen
that happened today okay the big
announcement happened today
okay well how did making that compare
to the movies that you made in the mcu
did it feel different in any noticeable
way going
taking the the film work and putting it
into a tv series
no not really i mean if you think about
uh what kevin feige has
done you know it's sort of like a grand
tv experiment anyway it's it's sequels
and spin-offs
right it's an episodic formula and
spin-off
uh formula like you had in
in you have had it in television forever
just done on a sort of grand scale in
film
so moving it to tv felt
and i think they made a really smart
decision you know ours is sort of an
homage to lots of
different uh eras and genres of
of american the american centuries
tv and um i
and the the different the difference is
this we had an awful lot of money
but we had to make six hours of tel six
hours
you know rather than two and a half or
whatever it was seven hours i can't i
don't know
eight hours i don't know but a lot of
hours
of the same amount of money that we
would usually have to make two and a
half hours
okay so they did some very clever things
like
we shot the first episode in two days in
front of a live studio audience we
basically ran it twice with three
cameras
running between sets and um and
and and that allows you to bank all of
that time for all of the action
and we cross-bordered you that's the
other thing we cross-boarded the
entire um show because we have one
director
which meant that you could bang that
time usually you have
two episodes with the director and then
you know so so
they they they boxed clever and they
made some pretty um
smart decisions about how we shot the
early episodes to
it so that we could um
have a lot of time at the end to try and
keep the same sort of production value
because of how bonkers it all looks
does it feel like it's intrinsically
connected to the mcu or does it feel
like it's more of its own thing or
both of those things true i think it's
going to make you think about the mcu in
a very
in a whole brand new way but i do
think that it is um it's absolutely a
part of that universe
it a as each episode unfolds
you will the the audience will be able
to
peel back layer upon layer until this
rather
beautiful puzzle box written by jack
schaefer
and directed by matt shachman and shot
by jess hall
it will be revealed to everybody and it
will make sense
and all of that bonkers stuff will be
about something
you mentioned exploring different eras
is it
paying homage to a lot of different eras
is it mostly 50s and 60s
50s 60s 70s 80s 90s yeah
all of it and then we end up in
mcu uh
the real world
[Laughter]
yeah well alan do you feel like you have
another tv show in you is that something
that
is that the next thing you might do or
are you looking more at film
yes i'm in it
[Laughter]
it's called uncle frank on ice
absolutely as far as an open-ended tv
show that would run for seasons and
seasons
no i'm too old for that
um but i am working right now i'm
working on a pitch for a limited series
uh
television show um i'm working on a
pilot uh
for a tv show that is just uh doing
writing it for myself it's a show i
would like to see
whether anybody wants to do it or not
we'll we'll see
i've got several movies i've written
that uh
i've been trying to get made over the
years and
with uh not much success uh but uh maybe
one of those will go or maybe
i you know i did during during
quarantine i did write a slasher movie
about a bunch of frat boys who go on a
ski trip and somebody starts killing
them one by one
okay and i hate frat boys so let's go
um so i think i had some anger to work
out
you think uh so we'll see
i don't know it's it's not up to me it's
it's it's sort of uh
whatever i have that anybody wants to
actually
pay to hire cameras to start shooting
will probably be the next thing i do
because then now i desperately want to
and need to see the slasher movie like
that
just really has to happen now
well we'll see uh several people have
passed on it already so
we'll uh maybe we'll find somebody that
wants to make it
the the limited series that you
mentioned is it like another
ensemble family i mean you're so good at
that is that
something that you want to do again or
is it very different
um it's about uh are you in la
los angeles well it's about um the
family that created
the zanku chicken uh restaurant
there's one of those very nearby well
it's a family of
immigrants a family of armenians who
came to america and created this uh
um this restaurant franchise and
uh it it it ends in like insane
tragedy and uh there was a double murder
and of suicide
um so it's it's it's light it's very
light
fair we'll see we're we're just at the
pitching stage so
paul how how long do you think it'll be
before you take on that second movie as
a director
[Music]
oh gosh i don't know um
i i got a i wrote something during
quarantine
um that i with my friend
that i really like is a comedy about
um about his life he
he he um he and his wife got divorced
and then um about a month later all had
to quarantine together and it struck me
as hysterically funny
that's great situation and so i'll i'll
send it you out and i'd love you to hear
it but
the truth is nobody wanted to make a
movie about quarantine
um it's not really about quarantine um
but
right now there was a lot of pushback on
yeah we just don't think people want to
see that right now they want to kind of
forget about it but um
um it's got lots of jokes in it and
they're pretty good jokes
so i thought it'd be really nice to do
something that was
funny this time i'll send it you all and
i i i'm proud
i'm really proud of it i'd like to hear
your thoughts maybe if somebody wanted
to give me the money to make that i'd
i'd love to do that it's very contained
and can be shot during a lot now
well i appreciate both of you guys
talking about this i thought it was such
a beautifully told story i
certainly was crying more than once so
thank you for that
and for this movie and for talking to me
about it i appreciate it
absolutely thank you christina thank you